an increasingly desperate panicked and
unhinged failed former president Donald
Trump released a cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs
midnight video last night early this
morning wherein he calls all four
investigations into him just Democratic
left-wing bias in yet another sign that
he is both not only really scared but
very very disconnected from reality this
video was released through Rumble and
embedded on Troth Central here is Trump
very late at night claiming that the
weight of his massive polling lead where
did you think I was going with that the
weight and size of his massive polling
lead is forcing desperate Democrats to
try to charge him of course ignoring the
reality that these investigations have
been going on for a long time before he
was even a candidate for 2024. let's
take a look these four horrible radical
left
investiga by the way I I know people
seeing this are going to write to me and
say David how can you not comment on the
fact that it's not even orange that
Trump is anymore it's almost like he
he's he's painted himself so dark that
it doesn't even make any sense and his
lips look white and folks I get it I get
it I but it's not the focus here I get
that he looks like a like a reverse mime
I guess we would say but we're not
focusing on that here
your all-time favorite President me
is just a continuation of the most
disgusting Witch Hunt in the history of
our country it's gone on forever with
Russia Russia Russia and Ukraine Ukraine
Ukraine and the Muller hoax it's an
absolute disgrace what's going on they
even spied on my campaign of course
that's not true should I explain that
again I guess I'll briefly just be it's
been a while I just I if you know the
explanation I apologize the the
allegation from Trump is that they spied
on my campaign
what happened was that Trump's 2016
campaign was in touch with so many
suspected criminals who were themselves
under surveillance that when those
suspect suspected criminals would make
phone calls to people associated with
Trump
's Associates Associates would
incidentally be surveilled because they
were talking to suspected criminals they
weren't spying on Trump's campaign
and remember this with all of the work
that they did on Mueller no collusion
that's what the answer was was all no
collusion whether it's the Mar-A-Lago
raid or the unselect committee hoax
the perfect Georgia phone caller was
absolutely perfect or the stormy horse
face Daniels extortion plot there it is
they're all sick
and its fake news our enemies are
desperate to stop us because they know
that we are the only ones who can stop
them and they know it very strongly and
they're looking at the polls where not
me but we are up by so much they can't
believe it is that true we'll look at
that we won twice and now we've got to
win a third time they know that we can
defeat them they know that we will
defeat them but they're not coming after
me they're coming after you right this
is a classic which is by trying to hold
me accountable for crimes for which
there is evidence
you are really being targeted it's like
no no no they're targeting you for the
things you allegedly did
I'm just standing in their way right and
I always will stand in their way thank
you very much that video released just
after the stroke of midnight early this
morning and of course this unhinged
panicked and desperate as ever all four
investigations are merely Democrats
going after Trump because the polls are
so great for Trump the truth is that the
polls are good for Trump they're not
absolutely fantastic and in fact Trump
does worse against Joe Biden then does
Ron DeSantis just for uh being thorough
if you look at some recent polls yes
there continue to be polls in which
Trump is doing very well in the
Republican primary but there are also
polls that are quite close
um and it really depends on which poll
you look at these are Republican primary
polls and Trump is winning depending on
the state or whether it's a general poll
anywhere from between 2 and 28 over Ron
DeSantis but these are not big surges
these are worth what the numbers have
been and then importantly if you look at
the general election
uh Biden against DeSantis versus Biden
against Trump Biden does better against
Trump in every one of these recent polls
so it's not really true that there's a
polling motivation to try to get Trump
out of the way if you are Democrats and
by the way Democrats justice department
Biden in D.C prosecutor D.A in New York
the Georgia these are all different
groups is the truth and just to say
these are just all Democrats is also not
accurate but the idea that Democrats
would be saying let's charge Trump to
get him out of the way why DeSantis does
better than trump it wouldn't make any
sense to try to do that
imagine for a second that you try
logging into your email account only to
find that your password was changed an
hour ago and then you get notifications
of activity from your bank and then your
credit cards that is what identity theft
is like and it's a horrible feeling and
we dealt with it at the show not that
long ago but now I have an app called
Aura which gives me much more peace of
mind our sponsor Aura is the all-in-one
solution for keeping your online account
safe because Aura will scan the dark web
for your personal info passwords social
security number and you get fast alerts
when they find something you also get
fast alerts about credit inquiries Aura
protects all of your devices from
malware or even requests the removal of
your info from data broker sites and
Aura helps you manage what your kids can
do on their devices you can restrict
certain apps set screen time limits set
Focus times when you need them off of
devices is go to aura.com Pacman to try
it free for seven days your login
credentials might already be floating
around out there and Aura will tell you
instantly for free the link is down
below